[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
Thank you so much.
All right.
I'm going to start with
a question for you all.
Is anybody hungry?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Excellent.
So Chef [? DeeDee ?]
and her team
are going to prepare some
great food for us after this.
But you have to just bear
with me for a second.
We're going to get to enjoy
these breakfast sandwiches.
Pretty simple breakfast
sandwich-- cheese, sausage,
eggs.
But first, we've just
got to do something
before you all get to eat this.
Hold on.
Just bear with me.
[POURING WATER]
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
We're getting ready.
Now, you might be
wondering why I just
dumped an entire gallon of
water down the drain, why
I would go and waste all
that water, especially
during Earth Week here on
Environment Day at Google,
no less.
Well, to produce just the single
egg in this breakfast sandwich
that we're going to
eat, we have to dump out
not one but 53 gallons of water.
That's how much water it takes
to produce just a single egg--
53 gallons.
To produce sausage,
that's another 500 gallons
of water; and cheese, that's
another 50 gallons of water.
That's what it takes to
produce protein from animals.
In the 15 years that I've
been researching food systems
and advocating for
a better one, I've
come to realize that the
number one most wasteful aspect
of our food system today
comes from the fact
that we use animals
as a middleman.
So here's what I mean--
first, we grow crops.
We don't feeds those
crops to humans.
First, we feed them to
animals to fatten them up.
We raise the animals.
We transport them to slaughter.
And the rest is history.
So animals are just
kind of middlemen
between the crops we
produce to feed them
and the protein they
produce to feed us.
The problem is it's
super inefficient.
Even in the best
cases, a farm animal
converts only like
11% of what's called
"feed energy" into human food.
That means that
calorically speaking,
89% percent of what we put
into an animal is wasted.
And nearly all of these animals
in our food supply chain
are chickens.
We're so knee-deep
in chickens today
that every 60 seconds,
every single day,
130,000 of these
animals are slaughtered.
If you can imagine that--
130,000 animals every minute
of every day, 24/7, 365.
That's a lot of animals,
and it's taking a toll.
Because it's so inefficient to
funnel crops through animals
to get to protein, we lose loads
of resources in the process--
like all that water.
The meat, dairy, and egg
industries, all told,
are so wasteful,
they're so inefficient,
that they now cause
more greenhouse gas
emissions than every car,
truck, plane, ship, and train
in the world combined.
But the problems aren't just
global, they're local, too.
I met this woman
recently named Lisa,
who lives on the eastern
shore of Maryland
on land that's been
part of her family
for like four generations.
Totally normal
neighborhood in most ways.
Picture any suburban
neighborhood,
split-level homes,
toys in the front yard,
basketball hoop in the driveway.
But Lisa and her
husband Joe, they're
being pushed off their land.
They're probably going to
have to sell their house soon.
They're not being pushed
out by crime or drugs
or high-rise condos.
They're being pushed
out by chickens.
See, having moved into
their neighborhood
are these massive
chicken warehouses
containing 10,000 birds, 20,000
birds, right in their backyard.
I visited them last
year, and I was really
moved to see how
just kind of peppered
throughout their
neighborhood are
these massive warehouses now.
I saw the hoards of
flies in the air.
I smelled the stench.
I saw buzzards flying
overhead constantly,
ready to pick off dead chickens
littering the side of the road
all up and down
their neighborhood.
I had to see all
this on one day,
but Lisa and Joe
and their neighbors,
they have to live with
it every single day
right in their backyard.
So we have to ask ourselves,
does this still make sense?
We've used animals
as that middleman
to get to protein for
thousands of years,
but do we still have to?
In 2018, if breakfast
sandwiches didn't exist
and we wanted to build
one from the ground up,
using what we have
available today,
we wouldn't look towards
chickens to produce the eggs
and we wouldn't look towards
pigs to produce the sausage.
In the same way that if the
idea of watching movies at home
was somehow brand new to us in
2018, the thing we wouldn't do
is go out and build
physical video rental stores
to have to drive
to on Friday night.
We use science and technology to
cut out middlemen all the time.
And the same is
happening with food.
And rather than
growing all these crops
and funneling them through
animals, raising the animals,
slaughtering them
to get to protein,
we can just use the protein
that's already found in plants.
And the food industry
is doing this.
They're making chicken
without chickens.
They're making
plant-based burgers
that have more protein
than beef in them.
They're making pork without
pigs, and even cheese
from nuts instead of cows.
These products are way
more efficient to produce.
They require less water and
less land and other inputs.
And they're also better for us.
Plant-based proteins tend to
have less fat, less saturated
fat.
They have zero cholesterol,
since cholesterol only
comes from animal proteins.
But what if we want real meat?
I'm not talking about
meat made from plants,
but actual flesh, actual tissue,
real muscle, without animals?
Impossible, right?
In 1931, Winston
Churchill was asked
to predict what the world would
look like in a half a century--
so by the '80s.
And he predicted that we shall
escape the absurdity of growing
a whole chicken in order to
eat the breast or the wing
by growing those
parts separately
under a suitable medium.
Well, it didn't happen
by the '80s, which
is what Churchill predicted,
but it's happening now.
It's called clean meat.
And like clean energy,
it's way more resource
efficient to produce.
We can now take a biopsy the
size of a poppy seed from just
a single chicken feather--
just the feather--
and from that,
grow enough nuggets
to feed an army or a village.
So these innovations are
shifting our relationship
with food at the cellular level.
Because what we eat
is really an extension
of what it is to
be human, I believe
that fundamentally
changing our relationship
with food in this way can serve
to elevate our own humanity.
I think it can lead to a
kinder more compassionate world
for everybody.
We humans are an
amazing species.
We're capable of really
wonderful things.
We've got a spark of
imagination and creativity
that's unparalleled in the
rest of the animal kingdom.
We're the only species on the
planet that can see the stars,
dream about what
might be up there,
and then actually
go and find out.
There's so much
about us as a species
that really is unique to us.
But at the same time, we
also share so much in common
with the rest of
the animal kingdom--
joy, play, communication.
Do you all know
that chickens use
complex vocalizations to
communicate with one another?
Just like we do.
They have different calls
to alert one another
when a predator is approaching
by land versus by air.
Fish can learn and use tools.
Pigs rank higher on
intelligence tests
than three-year-old humans do.
And, of course, we all
want to avoid pain.
We all want to avoid suffering.
Every animal wants
to avoid fear.
If through our
diets we can learn
to really value these
similarities that we share
with other species
rather than just focusing
on our differences, I think it
would bring tremendous value
to how we treat one another.
So a fish was born with
gills instead of lungs,
so a chicken was born with
wings instead of arms,
if we can extend our
circle of compassion
to those beings even
most unlike ourselves,
how might we extend it
to our fellow humans?
To those born black
instead of white or gay
instead of straight?
To those born in another
country than we were?
Can you picture a world
where we take so seriously
this idea of value
in our similarities
rather than just always
focusing on our differences
that it extends even to
the food we choose to eat?
What about a world where
we're happier, where
we're plagued less by disease?
A world where we're healthier?
A world with a
more stable climate
where we do more with less?
My road to picturing this world
came about many years ago.
When I was about 12,
my sister came home
from school a vegetarian.
This was in the
early '90s, if you
couldn't guess by the clothes.
And I never even heard the word
"vegetarian" before, let alone
met one.
So what I do, like any
good little brother,
I made fun of her.
You can imagine, with that hair,
I was the making fun of her.
I'd put a piece of steak
on the end of my fork
and put it in her face
and make a mooing sound.
My mom, fortunately, was much
more accommodating than I was.
If she had a pot of beef chili
for the two of us on the stove,
she'd have a pot of bean chili
next to it for my sister.
If she was grilling
hamburgers in the backyard,
she'd have a veggie
burger out there, as well.
And I liked food.
I wasn't opposed
to trying new food.
So I started to try some
of these weird, new foods.
And I liked them.
I was no vegetarian, though.
If I had a black bean burger,
I would put bacon on it.
If I had a bean burrito
one day for lunch,
I'd made sure to have
chicken for dinner,
just to balance it out.
Eventually, I did learn
more and more and more
about the reasons for
my sister's new diet,
and I also moved
in that direction.
So if you haven't
guessed by now,
our breakfast sandwich
that we're going to enjoy
isn't made from cheese
and sausage and eggs.
The cheese is made from almonds.
The sausage is made from
[INAUDIBLE] protein.
The eggs are made
from chickpea flour.
The whole thing is entirely
plant-based, without animals,
and it's delicious.
So that world
where we're kinder,
where we're more
compassionate, the world
where our meals are
extensions of our morals,
that's a better
world for all of us.
And I know that
all of us have it
within us to serve as
ambassadors for that world.
Every time we sit
down to eat, we
can be a good example for
our friends and neighbors,
at school, at church,
at work; a good example
for our little brothers
and little sisters.
And millions of people are
doing it all over the country.
People are trying
Meatless Monday.
They're eating smaller
portions in meat.
They're moving meat from
the center of the plate
to the side of the plate.
They're doing one or
two veggie meals a day.
Saving the world really
can be as simple as that.
And it begins with every bite.
So thank you so much.
And I am happy to
field any questions.
I know Marty's got
a couple that we're
going to kick things off with.
SPEAKER 2: Sure thing.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Excuse me.
And thank you so much.
It's kind of sobering to
see some of the statistics,
it really, truly is.
Would you mind taking
us through a little bit
how you got started
in the culinary arts
and what kind of led
you to this journey
to decide to publish
a book on the subject
that you're so passionate about?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I always loved cooking.
I always loved being
in the kitchen.
It felt comfortable there.
When I was really
little, I think
one of my first
projects in the kitchen
was I would take all the
spices out of our spice cabinet
and organizing them to combine
all the little half jars
of cinnamon and little
half containers of pepper.
When I was probably
about eight, I
started cooking
really simple meals.
I would make scrambled
eggs in the microwave,
which I don't recommend.
It's about as good--
SPEAKER 2: [LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: --as it sounds
like it's going to be.
SPEAKER 2: Even with one of
those cool little contraptions
off of As You Can See on TV?
SPEAKER 1: Just in a mug.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Not very good.
But I just always loved cooking.
And then, especially when I
became vegetarian and then
when I became vegan,
I realized that there
was like this whole
culinary world
out there that I
had no idea about.
I'd never tried Thai food.
I'd never tried Indian food.
I didn't even know that
these things existed--
Ethiopian food, tofu, tempeh.
Just all kinds of new tastes and
textures and flavors that I'd
never even heard about before.
And that started me
on my culinary path
was just realizing
that there was
a whole world of
textures and flavors
out there for the taking.
SPEAKER 2: Fantastic.
And you mentioned
your being a vegan.
And from a chef's
perspective, a lot
of times when we hear vegan--
for folks that are
non-vegans-- it's
veganism being the only answer
to dietary problems and issues
that we may face.
Your approach is
less about being
a vegan specifically and more
about a complete plant-based
approach.
Can you speak a
little bit about why
you chose that route
versus the typical approach
that this veganism is
the only way to go?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I think that there
is, literally,
a seat at the
table for everybody
when it comes to
plant forward eating,
when it comes to using our
diets as a tool for good
in the world.
Whether you're vegan, whether
you're a vegetarian, doing
Meatless Mondays, whether
you've only ever eaten
one plant-based meal
in your entire life,
I just think that
there is a place
for everybody on the spectrum.
A lot of people now are
doing Meatless Mondays.
They're just eating
smaller portions
of meat, like I mentioned,
or just literally
moving meat from the
center of the plate
always to being more
of a luxury item
or on the side of the plate.
And I think that's the
way change happens.
It takes everybody.
Regardless of what diet we might
adhere to or try to adhere too,
it's like all hands
and forks on deck.
SPEAKER 2: Absolutely.
Do you find that that approach
has yielded a better reception
from folks that maybe
are not vegetarian
or not vegan at all versus
the traditional approach
that that's been out
there in years past?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
There's a study that came
out recently from a company
called Mintel, a research group.
And they found that there are
about 22 million Americans who
consider ourselves vegetarian,
but 113 million who
say they regularly eat
meat alternatives--
so, veggie burgers and
other products like that.
So there are way more people
who are eating vegetarian food
than actually are vegetarian.
So without a doubt that's what
most people are doing nowadays.
SPEAKER 2: I think
as we're starting
to learn some of the effects
that Matthew pointed out
in his presentation of
the raising of livestock
on our environment-- and
it's still a fairly new thing
that I think we're
starting to wrap
our heads around a
little bit, and the news
is getting out there.
But I think my
question to you is
given that you've been
passionate about this for such
a long time, how did you
get into that piece of this
and connect a vegan or
plant-forward lifestyle
to the environment at
such an early stage?
SPEAKER 1: I've always
been passionate, I guess,
about environmental issues.
I'm a child of the '80s, when
you couldn't turn on the TV
without hearing
about global warming.
Does everybody remember that?
It was just everywhere.
Now, we call it climate
change, of course.
Back in the '80s, everybody was
talking about global warming.
And so I just started learning
about it from a young age.
The thing that really made
me move forward with my diet,
I think, was I mentioned
how my sister came home
from school a vegetarian
and I made fun of her.
I didn't really get it.
But we'd always had
animals at home.
We always had pets.
We had cats; we had dogs.
And I loved them.
Like most people,
always kind of just
shared a bond with animals.
And I guess a few years after
my sister had proclaimed herself
vegetarian, I
stumbled upon a video
of what happens to animals
in the livestock sector.
The way that they're--
without getting too graphic,
the way that they're
confined in cages and
crates barely larger
than their own bodies,
the way they're inhumanely
treated and slaughtered.
And it just hit me that--
my dog, Kelsey, at home, a
German shepherd; my cat teaser,
a black cat--
if I wouldn't want those
things done to those animals,
I shouldn't be
paying somebody to do
those things to other animals.
And all of a sudden,
I just got it.
I understood why my sister
had become vegetarian.
And that was really the thing
that pushed me over the edge.
After I changed my
diet, that's when
I started learning
more about the impact
that my old diet had on the
environment, about water usage
and land usage
and climate change
and that connection
to what we eat.
But for me, it was just wanting
to be kinder to animals.
SPEAKER 2: In terms of some
of your favorite ingredients,
what are some things that
you cannot live without,
whether it's at your home or
things in the book that you
think are a key thing for
someone to have in their pantry
as they start this journey?
SPEAKER 1: Nuts.
Definitely nuts, unless
you have a nut allergy.
Sorry.
I don't, so I use a lot of them.
Nuts are a really amazing food.
We can do so much with them.
We can soak cashews,
blend them up
with just a little
bit of water and salt,
and make a cheesy sauce.
If you've ever had
almond milk, that's
basically what almond milk is--
soaked almonds that have been
ground up and then strained.
That's essentially almond milk.
There are just so many
creamy, cheesy, milky sauces
and other kinds of products
that we can make using nuts.
There's a whole wide world
out there of nut-based foods.
Other great ingredients--
I love a product
called nutritional yeast.
SPEAKER 2: Mm-hm.
SPEAKER 1: I'd never heard
of it before I became vegan.
And I'm so glad
that I know about it
now because it's incredible.
Whether you're vegan or
not, sprinkle it on popcorn
and your life will be changed.
It's kind of got a Parmesan
cheese type flavor.
It's kind of sharp and tangy.
Really wonderful product.
SPEAKER 2: My wife
and I literally put it
on pretty much everything.
[LAUGHTER]
Whole Foods sells it.
I think Safeway now sells it.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Back in the--
I don't even know if we
could buy it in the '80s,
but certainly in the
'90s and the early 2000s,
it was like a vegan staple.
Now, more and more people
are catching on to it
and just think, wow,
this is a great food.
SPEAKER 2: And on that
note, with the rise of kind
of processed plant
proteins, I will say--
and you eluded to a few of
them in your presentation--
I think the Impossible
Foods burger up there--
how do those fit into
your plan and how do those
fit into your vision
as to how to round out
a plant-forward diet?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I eat processed foods.
I eat those types of
convenience foods.
There are all kinds of
plant-based, plant-forward,
meat-like but meat-free
products of veggie chickens
and the Impossible
Burgers and Beyond
Burgers that now they say
even "bleed" like meat does,
but all from
plant-based ingredients.
I love that stuff.
I eat it.
I would say mostly my
diet, just personally,
consists more of like whole
plant-based food items.
I like eating that stuff
on the go if I'm traveling.
There are a couple of
restaurants in my neighborhood
that serve that type of stuff.
I like to go there if I just
want like a juicy burger.
But, by and large, I just focus
on whole plant-based foods--
whole grains, legumes,
nuts, beans, tofu, tempeh--
products like that.
SPEAKER 2: Do you have a
favorite recipe in the book?
One that really speaks to you?
SPEAKER 1: I can't be biased
against my own recipes.
SPEAKER 2: It's like choosing
a favorite child, I suppose?
SPEAKER 1: That's right.
Yeah.
I tell all the recipes
I love them all equally.
SPEAKER 2: [LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: It's not true,
though, but I do say that.
Actually, one of my
favorite recipes in the book
isn't even my own.
It's for a basbousa cake,
which is a Middle Eastern type
of cake made from semolina flour
and simple syrup and coconut.
I got it from a friend of
mine who is Middle Eastern.
He donated the
recipe for the book.
It's the only recipe in
there that isn't mine,
and I think it's my
favorite one in the book.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: It's a
good one to choose.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: My final question
before we'll turn it over
to the audience to ask a
few questions is what advice
do you have for those of us that
are meat eaters at the moment,
looking to try and get more
into a plant-based diet
and maybe make that switch?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I would say just explore
foods that are out there.
For me, aside from the ethical
component of changing my diet,
the thing that I really got
the most out of it in terms of
was just opening up my
culinary experience.
Before I adopted a
plant-based diet,
I was eating pretty much
the same thing every day.
I was just a meat and
potatoes kind of guy.
I didn't really explore that
much when it came to food.
So I would just say there's
a whole wide world of foods
and ingredients out there
that you might find you love.
If you eat a beef burger, try
an Impossible Burger or Beyond
Burger.
Try veggie chicken.
It might not taste exactly the
same as chicken or as meat,
but you might like it just
as a different food product
unto itself.
Not to mention all
the different things
you can make kind of whole
grains and nuts and produce.
SPEAKER 2: Do we have any
questions out here-- yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious,
so almost everybody has--
SPEAKER 1: So the question
was about having our own food
for us in our yard.
I've always had gardens.
I love being able to just go out
and pluck food from the garden
and then come inside and eat it.
I know a lot of people
are doing more of that.
It's such an easy
way to get basically
free food and food that is
fresh and healthy all the time.
You know exactly what's
gone into growing it.
So, yeah, I highly
recommend it for everybody.
SPEAKER 2: Just to add
on a little bit to that,
too, for a lot of us there,
we don't have the time
to wait for a beet to grow
and then do the whole bit,
but I find even if you
have a tight little space,
just growing fresh
herbs on your patio
is a great way to get started.
You can throw them out there.
You can start picking
them immediately
if you buy them kind
of already grown.
So it's a really easy
way to start that going.
AUDIENCE: So thinking
about natural farming
and how animals--
SPEAKER 1: I mean, by and large,
heritage animals don't really
exist anymore.
There are very few
places that produce them.
Almost exclusively, all
the animals in our diet--
certainly here in the US and in
North America and in Europe--
are animals that have
been bred specifically
for the purpose of
industrial agriculture.
Whether in the future we're
using animals in our diet,
I'm not sure.
I don't know if we use
them as much as we are now,
if we use them more than we
are now, less, or not at all.
But I think the one thing that--
the point that I tried
to make in my book,
and I think the one thing that
pretty much everybody can agree
on now, whether
you're slaughtering
a chicken in your
backyard, whether you're
eating meat three
times a day, is
we've got to eat
less of this stuff
if we want to bring about
a better food supply.
There's no way that our
planet can sustain--
just in the US alone-- raising
10 billion land animals--
that doesn't even include fish--
raising 10 billion
land animals a year
under industrial
conditions, locked in cages,
locked in crates, just
totally decimating the land.
Because, at the end of
the day, the animal--
even if it's a heritage bird or
if it's an industrial-produced
animal--
the same equation applies
in terms of their conversion
of plant matter into protein.
And so regardless of the source,
we have to eat less of them.
A heritage chicken is
still eating grain,
for the most part, that may
have been grown on land that was
once the Amazon rain forest.
And so, yeah, I think it's
just-- it's all about less.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I guess the question
is also more--
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
The question was what
happens to all the animals
if we stop eating them?
These animals aren't
self propagating.
They're not out there
breeding themselves
under natural conditions.
We're breeding them
specifically for this purpose.
So when people eat less and
less and less animal products,
we breed less and
less of the animals.
It's just supply and demand.
So the question was basically
the energy costs of some
of the plant-based
convenience foods--
like veggie burgers and veggie
chicken and products like that.
I would say, from an
environmental standpoint,
by all means, the
closer we can get
to a whole, plant-based,
locally-sourced diet,
the better off we are.
Ultimately, though, even
the processed foods--
if they're
plant-based or better,
environmentally speaking,
because you cut out that
middleman--
if you take a chicken
nugget, for example--
a real chicken nugget
made of chicken--
you have to grow all the crops,
you have to process them still
in grain mills, you
have to transport them
all over the world.
Then, you feed
them to a chicken.
You raise the chicken,
slaughter the chicken,
and then you get protein.
Then, you take a
vegetarian chicken nugget,
for example, same process.
You still have to
grow the crops.
You have to process them.
You just turn it directly
into the chicken nugget
rather than going through
that middleman first.
Still has an
environmental footprint.
It's not, by any means,
a zero-footprint food.
But it's much more
efficient because you've
cut out that middleman.
But, yeah, at the
end of the day,
the closer we can get to whole
plant-based foods, the better.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have a sense of--
SPEAKER 1: So it totally
depends on the product.
And there isn't good,
clear data on it.
But we know, for example, that
a gallon of milk, I think,
is upwards--
it costs upwards of like
1,000 gallons of water.
Whereas, a gallon of soy
milk is more like maybe 100.
It depends on the
product, depends
on the brand and all of
that, but much more resource
efficient.
I'm sure you all are
familiar with Google Trends.
I hope everybody in here is.
But it's really interesting.
If you use Google Trends to
see what people are searching
for on the internet, if you
look at the word "vegetarian"
and the word "vegan," people
searching for the term
vegetarian has sharply
declined and people
searching for the word
vegan has sharply inclined.
And there's a point where--
I think it's like around
2005 or something-- where
people searching for the word
"vegan" just sharply go up,
while vegetarian
goes sharply down.
So I don't know if there
was a branding problem.
It seems like people are
really interested in it,
searching for it.
We see it more on
restaurant menus.
But I do think that
the term "plant-based"
or "plant-forward" resonates
a lot more with people,
for whatever reason.
Yeah.
The question was
about food allergies.
I would say find the brands that
work for you and stick to them.
There are great gluten-free,
for example, vegan,
plant-based convenience
foods out there.
The Beyond Meat
Burger is one example.
It's a gluten-free burger
that looks and taste
and bleeds just like beef,
but it's entirely plant-based
and also gluten free.
The bun, that's
another question.
But, yeah, a lot of the types
of plant-based convenience foods
do contain gluten in them.
So if you're allergic to that,
that's definitely a concern.
As far as other allergies go, I
get a lot of questions but nut
allergies, a lot of vegan or
plant-based dairy products now
are made from nuts--
almond milk, cashew milk,
cashew milk ice cream, sauces,
and cheeses and stuff like that.
I would say, ironically, Google
is your best friend on this.
If you cook at home, if
you Google "gluten-free,
plant-based milk," you're
going to get 1,000 recipes.
Just because of the way
your algorithm works,
the ones toward the
top are probably
going to be the best ones.
But if you have
additional allergies,
it's definitely
tough for eating out,
in general, even if
you're not trying
to eat a plant-based diet.
Yeah.
So the question was the
environmental impact
of chicken compared to beef.
Beef has its own
special set of problems.
Cows are very gaseous animals,
especially when they eat grass,
because of the way
their digestion works.
They emit a lot of methane,
which is a major problem.
Chickens emit less
methane on the whole.
But there's so
much more of them.
There's so much more chickens.
Because they're smaller,
we need more of them
to sustain the food supply.
So in the US, we have about
10 billion farm animals.
About 9.5 billion of those
animals are chickens.
Nearly all of them--
more than 9 out of every
10 animals in the US
is a chicken when it
comes to our food supply.
And so some of the
biggest problems related
to chicken farming are where
do we put all these animals?
That's why we put them into
suburban neighborhoods,
like the one I talked about.
Where does the waste go?
It ends up in the land.
It ends up in the waterways.
We have so many
chickens, we don't
know what to do with
them or their waste,
and it's a major
environmental catastrophe.
Cows-- also not a great.
A lot of methane
contribution from them
in terms of their
digestion process.
Seafood is another issue.
We're pulling so many
fish out of the ocean
now that scientists
say we're not
going to have any left by 2048,
which is not that far from now.
Fish farming, as well-- huge
environmental footprint.
I would say, on the whole,
moving more away from seafood,
more away from poultry,
more away from beef,
is probably the best bet.
SPEAKER 2: All right.
Well, I think now
we can get to--
SPEAKER 1: Speaking of--
SPEAKER 2: We have all
these ingredients here,
we might as well cook
a little bit, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So let's do it.
SPEAKER 3: Thank
you for being here.
SPEAKER 1: Take it away.
SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
Thanks, chef.
SPEAKER 2: Hey, thank you.
SPEAKER 3: So we're going to
work through a vegan breakfast
sandwich today.
Plant-based recipes and we
teach plant-based dishes
in Kitchen Sink every day.
So super excited about this one.
Maybe we can just keep
taking questions or just--
SPEAKER 2: I'll
answer this question
before we get asked-- yes.
We will get to taste this stuff.
Everybody will get some.
They're delicious.
So what do we have?
Talk us through some
of the ingredients
that we're going to be
playing with here today.
SPEAKER 3: So as far as the egg
goes, we have garbanzo flour,
chickpea flour--
of course, gluten
free, high in protein--
nutritional yest, which you
guys spoke with earlier.
Some salt and pepper
and some turmeric.
So it's pretty easy.
Just mix these
ingredients together.
SPEAKER 2: And Matthew, you
want to talk a little bit
about inspiration or a thought
process behind this dish?
I know we eluded to the
environmental impact
of this dish specifically
in your presentation.
But how did this come to be?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I think chickpea flour
is a great ingredient.
Like Chef [? DeeDee ?] said,
it's just high protein,
it's easy to work with.
You come out with a product that
you can make egg-like products
out of it.
I make potato pancakes using
chickpea flour instead of eggs.
Just really good for
you and good product.
And when you mix it
with water and you
let it sit for a little while,
you'll see what happens.
It turns into kind of a paste
that you can scramble up
a little bit like eggs.
Is it going to taste exactly
like eggs and look like them?
Definitely not.
But it's just a good
product in its own right.
I like to cook with
ingredients like this
that are just kind of
readily available and simple.
Where you think about making
an egg patty for a breakfast
sandwich, it's just chickpea
flour, a little bit of salt,
pepper, turmeric, a little
bit of olive oil and water,
and that's it.
Very easy to make at home.
SPEAKER 2: And minimizes the
allergens that we talked about.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And minimizes the allergens.
It's a gluten-free product for
all of you Celiacs in the room.
SPEAKER 2: Now, is this--
SPEAKER 1: That's
the English muffin
that we're going to eat it on.
It's not so much gluten free.
SPEAKER 2: Was this
something that you
were looking to try and
fill a void for something
that you had enjoyed prior
to your lifestyle change?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I think that-- when I think
about plant-based foods that
kind of look and feel
and taste somewhat like,
or in some cases a lot like,
their meat-based counterparts,
I think back to my
diet before I became
a vegan, before I ate
a plant-based diet,
I liked the food.
I liked the taste of meat.
I liked the taste of eggs.
For me, it had nothing
to do with the taste.
And so I still wanted
to eat those flavors,
or as close to
them as I can get.
And this is a great example
of just kind of something
I always enjoyed eating when I
was a kid, something I always
enjoyed eating before I
adopted a plant-based diet
and wanted to try to get
closer to as a vegan.
SPEAKER 2: Fantastic.
And I want to talk a little
bit about the sausage.
SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
So in the book--
there's great vegan
sausages on the market,
but you also include one
that you can make at home.
So we decided to do
that recipe, as well.
Definitely geared towards
the more European-style
with some sun-dried tomatoes
and some basil and some garlic.
But thinking about some other
profiles that we can do--
I mean, if you wanted
to go more kind
of along the Indian
spices, you could throw
in some ginger, some masala.
I think you could
really play around
with this recipe to make
whatever variety you wanted.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
That's the great thing
about plant-based proteins,
or at least kind of whole
plant-based proteins,
like tofu, tempeh, seitan--
which is what
we're using today--
is you can really play around
with the flavor profile
quite a lot.
If you're making sausage--
pork sausage-- at home, you can
obviously do the same thing.
But with plant-based proteins,
you just mix it right in there.
When you're making seitan, it's
vital wheat gluten and water,
basically.
And whatever spices and
herbs you want to use,
just throw them
right into the mix.
Whether you want to do
European or Italian flavoring
or Indian flavoring, African
spices, whatever it might be.
It's a really great product.
So in the cookbook, the
sausage patty that's
used in this breakfast
sandwich recipe,
I just recommend using a
store bought brand-- whatever
brand you happen to like.
This sausage recipe is
taken from another recipe
in the book, I think, right?
The sun-dried tomato
basil sausages?
SPEAKER 3: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: So Chef
[? DeeDee ?] is
kind of doing a
little mash up for us.
SPEAKER 2: A little creative
freedom there, Chef.
SPEAKER 3: That's right.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, that's right.
SPEAKER 3: So the
vital wheat gluten,
some of the dried spices,
all go in one bowl.
And then, the paste
and all the seasonings
are going to go in here.
Little bit of water.
And I'm going to puree
it with a hand blender.
But you could easily do a food
processor at home or Vitamix.
And then, we're going to mix
these two things together,
so pretty easy.
SPEAKER 2: And with seitan--
for me, in particular--
I like to look at seitan as
a completely blank canvas.
I mean, unto itself, it doesn't
really have much of a flavor,
but it kind of lends itself
to this exact creative freedom
that you can have to put
whatever you like in it.
There's recipes out there to
make seitan chorizo, where it's
the same flavors
of Spanish chorizo
that everybody loves in
the meat-eating world,
and some of the same texture,
but in a completely vegan
format.
And I try to encourage
people when they're
cooking to have
fun and experiment,
and not be afraid to
make something that
doesn't taste good
one time, and then
come back and try it again.
It's really, really important.
And I think that's
how you get to a place
where you have something
delicious like you've
created here.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And I think experimentation,
for me, is key in the kitchen.
And this was the
same way before I
adopted a plant-based diet was I
would experiment with foods all
the time, and come out with
things that were not something
I would want to eat ever.
I'm sure anybody
who cooks, I'm sure,
has the same experience
from time to time.
Some recipes are just duds.
SPEAKER 3: [LAUGH]
SPEAKER 1: And so I would
say with plant-based food,
just try different brands
that are out there.
Try different flavor profiles.
Try different ways of preparing
seitan and tofu and tempeh.
Some are going to be duds,
no doubt, because that always
is the case.
But you'll definitely
find some, I'm
sure, that you love,
some that are winners,
and that you stick with
all the time in your diet.
SPEAKER 2: So in
your book, you have
some pretty big
celebrities in there that
have given you a shout out--
SPEAKER 1: I should've
got you in there.
SPEAKER 2: I don't
know about that.
I'm not even in
that conversation.
Why did you select the
folks that you selected
to be a part of the book?
And how have they been
advocates for your movement?
SPEAKER 1: There
are a lot of great,
kind of notable people
in the world who
have been advocating for these
types of changes in our food
system.
So I tried to
incorporate, really,
anybody who had something
to say about it.
There are a lot of
essays in the book.
If you flip through--
I think everybody here probably
should have gotten a copy.
There are a lot
of essays in there
from people like Jesse
Eisenberg, the actor;
from the heads of the some of
the major environmental groups;
the president of NRDC
and the Sierra Club
have essays in there.
From the food world,
we've got folks
like Chef Jose Andreas has
an essay in the book called
Our Food Issues and How
They Impact the World.
And then, in terms
of endorsements,
people like Wolfgang
Puck and Emeril Lagasse
and Alice Waters
and Paul McCartney.
I was just very
fortunate to have
a lot of people kind of
support the project who
have started making the shift,
either in part or in whole
or at least recognize
that we've got to be
eating more plant-based foods.
Somebody like Wolfgang
Puck is a great example--
a very meaty chef, German chef.
Very meat heavy.
But believes that we ought to be
eating more plant-based foods,
and so lent his
voice to the project.
SPEAKER 2: And on
that front, I think
we've seen a shift
in recent years
to chefs having a voice in these
sort of political settings,
environmental settings.
How do you think the
voice of somebody
like Wolfgang Puck
can really continue
to drive this
conversation in a way
that we haven't had
advocates in the past?
SPEAKER 1: I think that the
major shift that happened
is that we see people from kind
of all parts of the spectrum--
from vegans to Wolfgang
Puck and pretty much
everybody in between--
who are now kind of
coalescing around
this idea of just eating more
plant-based foods and less
animal-based foods.
Whether you go whole hog--
no pun intended-- whether you go
whole hog towards a vegan diet.
SPEAKER 2: Let's be
honesty, pun was intended.
SPEAKER 1: Pun intended.
[LAUGHTER]
It actually wasn't, but it
should have been, though.
Whether you go fully in
that direction or not,
there's just--
so many people have
kind of coalesced
around this idea of eating
more plants, less meat.
SPEAKER 2: Fantastic.
What's our next step here, chef?
SPEAKER 3: All right.
One more thing, to build
out this sandwich--
I know you talked a little
bit about the vegan cheese--
but we did a cashew aioli.
Again, using nuts
for some great fats.
And then, we have lemon,
garlic, a little bit
of cayenne and paprika.
So just another idea
if you're building out
sandwiches at home.
And then, a little gem
lettuces, little bit of avocado.
So super excited to
share your recipe
with everybody in the room.
We're going to cook
up the chickpea egg,
and we're going to
sear up the sausages.
So kind of a made for TV,
made the breakfast sausage.
This is what it looks like.
Then, we steam off the patty,
and then you can brown it.
A couple of made for TV
things happening here,
but the recipe in the
book is fully detailed.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
A little bit of
TV magic in making
it happen so quickly, right?
SPEAKER 2: And then,
seitan's a fun ingredient
because you can play with the
hydration level a little bit
based on what desired
outcome you're looking for.
A little bit chewier,
you obviously add
a little bit less water;
a little bit softer,
you add a little more water.
And so your hydration content
will yield a different product
based upon what
you're looking for.
Was there a question here?
SPEAKER 1: It be fun to
do an entire cookbook
of cooking failures.
You can just call it
"Cooking Failures," like 100
of the worst recipes ever made.
I don't know if it
would sell that well.
So the question was a
plant-based mac and cheese
that was great at
the time it was
being eaten for the
first time, but leftovers
got a little bit grainy.
I would offer two
recommendations-- one,
it could've been
a product of not
blending the cashews
long enough or not
soaking them long enough.
So the longer you
soak it, the creamer
it's going to be
when you blend it up.
I usually soak them for at least
four hours, maybe even eight
if I have the time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: OK, yeah.
Soak them for a few
hours in advance,
and then blend them up.
And really blend the
heck out of them,
and they'll stay pretty creamy.
If it gets a little bit
grainy for leftovers,
I would say a quick fix would
be mix a little bit more water
and just give it
a couple of turns,
and then reheat it
to kind of get back
that creamy consistency.
SPEAKER 2: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: The recipe--
SPEAKER 2: They're
essentially one and the same.
So by boiling it, you're putting
it in a moist environment
to continue to
hydrate the seitan.
And the same thing with
the hydration level
when you add your water in,
steaming it or boiling it
for a longer period of time
will yield a tougher or softer
product, depending on how
you want to handle it.
So they are essentially
the same thing.
It's just putting it in a moist
environment to help it "cook."
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] same
amount of time [INAUDIBLE]??
SPEAKER 2: I would imagine so.
Honestly, I've never
steamed it before,
so I don't know if
it would be the same
or if it would be less,
to be perfectly honestly.
SPEAKER 3: We also did--
you can also do like a
slow poach or a slow simmer
with it, too.
So we have the steam oven here.
But, yeah--
SPEAKER 2: You gonna
try and flip it?
SPEAKER 1: You gonna
try to give it a flip?
SPEAKER 3: Go for it, chef.
SPEAKER 2: I'm
not going to do it
in front of all these people.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I know.
SPEAKER 3: I'm
using the spatula.
SPEAKER 2: Flip it.
SPEAKER 1: Everybody back up.
SPEAKER 2: We just talked
about culinary failures.
What a good environment.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, you got it.
You can flip it.
SPEAKER 2: Boom.
SPEAKER 3: Done.
Done.
SPEAKER 2: Don't be scared.
SPEAKER 3: Done.
SPEAKER 2: All right so--
SPEAKER 3: We're
getting close here.
We're getting close.
SPEAKER 2: So are we going
to just cut this out?
Yeah.
SPEAKER 3: So a couple of ways--
SPEAKER 2: So it'll
fit the size of our--
SPEAKER 3: --that we thought
about the egg, you can use--
you can buy an egg
ring, of course,
so it looks perfectly round
like a scrambled egg might be.
You could do it more
on this omelet style.
Laura talked about
using a red bell pepper
and you could cut up
slices, and then you
can create your own little
egg form to get it round, too.
So I think there's
lots of solutions.
SPEAKER 2: I've never
heard of that trick.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Basically, cut a ring out
of the red bell pepper,
and then pour the batter
into the ring of the pepper.
And then the pepper
cooks as the egg cooks.
SPEAKER 2: Huh.
SPEAKER 1: And you end up
with something-- you have
to eat the pepper at the end.
I guess you don't have to.
[LAUGHTER]
Another great thing you can do
if you don't own egg rings--
I may be the only vegan
on the planet that
owns egg rings at home--
but if you don't have
them, what you can do
is use the screw on top to a
Mason jar, just the part that's
hollow in the middle
and that screws
on, just grease that
up, put it in your pan,
pour it right in there and
you get a perfect circle.
SPEAKER 2: All right.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: In vegan
cooking, I've learned
one of my own little
tricks to fool you
into thinking you're eating
something traditionally--
SPEAKER 1: So the question
was what are some ingredients
that you can use to kind of
trick yourself into thinking
it's the animal-based version.
Honestly, I don't--
I don't try to trick
myself all that much.
I try to eat foods
that I think just taste
good in their own right.
Whether or not it's
a perfect analog
for a meat- or
animal-based version,
I just want it to taste good.
But I know what you mean.
Like black salt, as
an example you gave,
has kind of a
sulfuric taste to it
that makes it taste a
little bit more like eggs.
Turmeric is a good example.
If you're making tofu scramble
or something like that,
you want to just give it a
little bit of a yellow tint,
turmeric is a great idea.
Too much and it's going
to taste like Indian food,
but maybe that's a good thing.
Yeah.
There are all kinds of
ingredients out there
that can just give
you little nods
toward the animal-based version.
All right, Chef [? DeeDee. ?]
SPEAKER 3: What do you think?
SPEAKER 2: There we go.
SPEAKER 1: Looks great.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Very nice.
All right.
Well, I think that's what
we've got for you today.
And we have some sandwiches
here for anybody to taste.
I'd like to thank Matthew
again for being here
and sharing your story
and sharing your book
with all of us here today.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Thanks so much.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you so much.
It was a pleasure.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Thank you.
And thank you.
SPEAKER 3: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: I can't wait
to try your spin on it.
SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
Definitely.
We'll be passing out
sandwiches for everybody.
SPEAKER 2: Fantastic.
And thank you all
for joining us today.
I really appreciate
having you here.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]